if all the princesses had Twitter they
would hashtag me too oh goodness
goodness is something Snow White said
she would see like oh goodness me I was
oh nine like three years here are some
things you might not know about the
Disney theme parks we're to the main
entrance of Disney Hollywood studios
that was my job was basically just be
like smiling creepy security that just
like suggests people should leave I
worked in entertainment at Disney so I
did a lot of different roles I got to be
friends with Cinderella and Rapunzel I
was best friends with Princess Tiana so
friends with is the term used when you
play this character so I was Snow White
when you're at Disney there's only one
Cinderella Mickey Mouse runs it you're
not allowed to say I play Snow White or
I am Snow White
they didn't want anyone to know who I
was I couldn't post photos up this is me
as Snow White it was this is my friend
Snow White
what advice would I give someone going
to Disney the best time I would say to
go to Disney is any time other than the
summer summer sucks ass it's brutally
hot all the kids are there on vacation
there's just like waves of hot humanity
coming in during the summer so the best
time to go is think is in October most
of the time when I was working there I
didn't see people for like whole
half-hour stretches October in the
daytime it's actually pretty decent the
best time to go was immediately after
the holidays over after Christmas and
before Valentine's Day because the
weather is absolutely amazing
it should be perfect peachy peachy keen
that's what princess tiana would say i
really afternoon and the evening is the
best time because everyone's at lunch
babies and stuff like that or taking
naps back of the hotel right in the
middle there there's like a sweet spot
where you can just go to everything so
just like bring a bunch of snacks or
something and then hit up you know
Splash Mountain while the kids are
asleep
what are secret places only the cast
knows about definitely the tunnels
Disney's very good at hiding things
we have tunnels through every park
except for Animal Kingdom of a term for
it is called the Attila door the biggest
underground you will ever see in all the
Disney's Magic Kingdom is actually on
the second story because it floods so
much in Florida and then there's the
tunnels underground it's just like dark
and creepy creatures
or like half in costume but half not you
have your giant dressing rooms dining
halls you have everything we even have a
subway all of that underground the
underground tunnels oh my gosh that's
where the real villains are looking this
get for free if you get a cast member at
the right point of the day you can
literally just ask them can I have a
fast fast and they probably give it to
you I know sometimes they do this thing
where they pick someone and they give
them a free night and Cinderella's
castle or something like that or they'll
give them like an upgrade to a suite
those things are so hard to predict I
couldn't tell anyone like how to go
about doing it I've seen some people
give out hats as well which is really
cute and they always have those people
with their carts songs are nice to them
they can probably give you something for
free someone bumps into your popcorn
spills the cast members the employees
they will run up and switch it out and
they'll replace it for free ooh ooh you
ready okay this is what you can get for
free because Disney loves extend the
magic and make all the guests happy you
can complain enough to where you could
possibly sometimes skip the line to see
like on an Elsa or to see Princess Tiana
and príncipe V you'd have to complain to
the right person when we're at the main
entrance we pick like a random family
and then we'd roll out the red carpet
and they come in and it's like very cute
there's like fake paparazzi and stuff
like that but if there's definitely
something for like every area of the
park I would just ask one of the sweet
old people in the morning the cast
members really are passionate about
trying to make magic for everyone if
they can do something they more than
likely will particularly you know for
people that are just really sweet really
nice what should people do when they
need a princess oh yes oh my gosh I have
so much advice always say yes we're here
to have fun like play along the more you
play along the more the more you get out
of it more fun it is for you and them
being yourself interact naturally like
don't be too shy and hold back because
the more you interact them well we feel
what they feel this characters that they
can be themselves just be nice be
friendly be quick because we're trying
to get through as many people as we can
and then number two is just if you can
kind of sit back and relax a little bit
and just kind of like hold your camera
and watch versus trying to direct the
whole interaction the kids are going to
be more comfortable
so they're gonna like open up and
they're gonna talk more some of the
little kids get really frisky and they
want to go inside the dress are going to
meet address and Tiana's dress is one of
the biggest layouts it's got like eight
hoops they'll try to go in and meet the
dress and one time the child got stuck
on I mean if you have an infant do not
put them on a Disney Princesses or
prints or characters anyone's lap
because I've seen explosions I'm just
don't put your baby on anyone at Disney
weshould Park colors avoid the
characters at like Park capacity that's
when you start seeing all these
characters because they're trying to
peel people away from the lines of the
lines go down if you start seeing like
Rafiki or something like the more
obscure characters they're just there
just to like peel you up but don't fall
for it
see the characters they're not there all
day and then do the rise definitely
avoid the bathrooms at the front of the
park they're just so crowded so there
tends to be hidden ones everywhere in
terms of food the turkey legs are
delicious but they are literally like
2,000 calories so I would split it with
a friend stay away from any crazy beer
the Japan pavilion and Epcot called the
frozen Japanese beer it's literally just
like if at 7-eleven you poured a miller
lite beer slushy and it cost like
fourteen dollars it was like the worst
thing I've ever tasted my entire life
have I ever been propositioned well in
character oh my gosh all the princesses
had twitter they would hashtag me too to
be honest with you you'd be like very
shocked
the brazen things people do i've been
proposed to many a times people have
attempted to kiss me both male and
female please don't be a creep when you
go meet the princesses there are people
too and most of them are married so just
like avoid that the children they'll
pull the petals down on a corset that
reveals Tiana's you know extra beignets
don't try to kiss them don't be too
handsy princesses do give out kisses
sometimes to little boys and girls big
boys and girls no they do not
so just don't ask we get it all the time
the daddies would come up and they'd be
like Prince Tiana's fine and then Tiana
be like all right right over here so
don't be touching my beignets
if you inappropriate
touch any of the characters you will be
arrested if you inappropriately make a
comment you will be kicked out of the
park
the characters are all humans - I did
actually date Snow White's prince for
that it's a lot of the princesses find
their princes at the Magic Kingdom they
can turn into drink on shoes or
nightmares where do people go to hook up
ooh yeah well there's look at the
classic lake you go to the castle
whatever that's probably a good date
people just make out all over the place
in Disney it's kind of a little yeah
it's yeah you're you'll be in the parade
and you're like waving to people and
you're like oh there they are
oh now look at you two - the five
flashes friendly together down the bayou
maybe you guys could actually skip on
down to the Magic Kingdom that would be
perfect see a firework show Epcot I feel
like it's just like a lawless land no
one really cares a spaceship earth I
imagine that's a good makeout ride
because nobody's really paying attention
if I was to bring a date I would go
there the best place I can think of to
go to be alone and I don't know from
personal experience Morocco in Epcot
where you can drink around the world
Morocco has a lot of places that are
just like off the path and you just get
you away from the rest of the park me
and my buddies the thing was just like
finding places to smoke weed basically
there's like pavilions that they made in
like 1993 that some ride broke down and
like nobody cares because it's Epcot
this thing pavilion are supposed to be
about the human body
so there was this whole ride there was
like called body Wars and now it just
sits there and nobody guards it so you
can have your own body Wars so to speak
thank you for watching I hope you got to
learn a lot of tips and tricks all right
by you you get it but it's like by you
but it's still reference to the value
hmm you got a deal a little tea yes okay
hey guys do you know it's Hispanic
Heritage Month nobody you guys from
Loyola team of content right here